bonjour à tous bienvenue à bruxelles au
parlement européen c'est parti pour 30
minutes d'actualité sur l'europe cette
semaine on s'intéresse au travail
détachées souvenez vous c'était au
milieu des années 2000 l'europe se
déchiraient déjà sur la directive
bolkestein et le plombier polonais
quelques années plus tard force est de
constater que le travail des tâches et
pose toujours problème dans de nombreux
pays et restent souvent synonyme de
dumping social avant d'en discuter avec
mes invités mounir soucy s'est rendu en
belgique pour un état des lieux
reportage
alors ici on est sur les hauteurs de
liège sur le parking de barchon on
appelle ça un lieu très important ou pas
mal de camions s'y installent pour faire
leurs coupures et on peut voir mais pas
d'immatriculation qui sont là portugais
un hollandais et les conditions de vie
un entre deux camions et mange
vive la vie un quotidien difficile pour
ces chauffeur bulgare slovaque polonais
mais en prenant la route ils peuvent
gagner le double du salaire moyen dans
leur pays pour réduire leurs coûts des
transporteurs belges profitent de ces
écarts de salaire et ouvre directement
des filiales en europe de l'est
le fait qu'il soit installé en tchéquie
c'est que ils peuvent engager des gens
avec un contrat slovaques qu'ils soient
slovaque où vous un peu importe
n'importe qui et puis sûrs met à
disposition un véhicule qui est souvent
pris sur belgique et il travaille au
départ de la belgique avec un contrat
slovaque 500 euros brut par mois en
général
cette main d'oeuvre moins chère permet à
ces entreprises de remporter la majorité
des contrats de transport longue
distance laissant au chauffeur belge les
livraisons sur des petits trajets
nationaux frontaliers en belgique
la profession a perdu 6000 postes en une
décennie et sur cette période
le métier a muté au fesf au parlement la
tour d'anne lise thériault excuses aux
clients ils prennent le travail tout
simplement bon on peut pas leur en
vouloir
il faut qu'ils vivent aussi mais on peut
pas se permettre de continuer comme ça
l'europe sociale
elle est où c'est d'augmenter les
salaires et la paix place qui soyons
même niveau qu'à nous en attendant cette
harmonisation les sociétés de transport
tente de rester compétitive sur ce
marché ouvert
bertin entreprises belges ont cherché
des solutions d'aucune respecte
parfaitement la réglementation d'autres
plus on porte à faux avec les règles
nous estimons que dès lors qu'on
respecte les règles européennes il n'y a
pas de raison de leur en vouloir
les acteurs qui reste dans les clous
réclame plus de contrôle et de sanction
contre les tricheurs
le gouvernement tente de lutter contre
la fraude il affirme avoir récupéré 200
millions d'euros l'année dernière et
annonce le recrutement de 100
inspecteurs de recouvrement
supplémentaires mais ils misent avant
tout sur une initiative européenne pour
mettre fin aux dérives qu'en 2014 on a
quand même voter une directive
d'exécution 4 en train d'implémenter
maintenant hein ça veut dire par exemple
qu'on peut travailler ensemble beaucoup
plus facile avec les services
d'inspection des pays tiers donc c'est
un élément clé pour nous deuxièmement
les la proposition de madame test au
niveau européen pour la révision de la
directive et là on donne beaucoup de
soutien à madame test pour clarifier la
définition pour avoir un peu meilleure
collaboration entre différents services
d'inspection et ça veut aussi dire qu'on
est beaucoup plus facile on en voit
beaucoup plus de capacités pour
contrôler les règles ici en belgique
la commissaire européenne mariann 6n à
la mission d'instaurer un alignement des
salaires vers le haut
en accordant aux travailleurs détachés
les acquis sociaux en vigueur dans les
pays d'accueil
une mise à niveau attendu dans le
secteur du transport mais aussi de la
construction en belgique
un tiers des employés du bâtiment sont
détachés les temps sont durs pour les
entreprises qui embauchent exclusivement
de la main d'oeuvre locale dans la
banlieue de liège ce patron a bien du
mal à décrocher des appels d'offres
publics les administrations parce le
marché au moins 10 or moi je me vois mal
exploité de guerre pendant deux mois et
plus leur donner le papier parce que je
vais faire venir un autocar de gauche de
droite c'est pas dans la mentalité c'est
peut-être ridicule de parler comme ça
certains certaines se frotte les mains
en agissant de la sorte mais je ne
connais pas encore arrivé à ce polar
bien qu'on vient de passer deux années
très difficiles
un état d'esprit qui pourrait se révéler
payant à quelques kilomètres dans la
ville d'herstal le nerf prépare un
chantier donc ici on va avoir une voirie
d'accès qui va venir il y encore des
bâtiments qui veut a fait démolir ce
bâtiment la flüela il a mis en place un
dispositif pour soutenir les entreprises
responsables lorsque nous lançons a
marché un marché ouvert
tout le monde peut répondre mais pour ne
pas être exclu du marché
il faut dans l'offre avoir l'adhésion à
cette charte une charte de bonne
conduite pour envoyer un message est
lancé une dynamique même si la valeur
juridique de ce texte et limiter les
mesures qui devraient prises pour lutter
contre le dumping social ne sont pas
toujours prises ou ne sont pas
pleinement prise et donc au niveau local
on peut avoir un complément d'actions où
on ne maîtrise plus grande sur la
décision
l'initiative fait tache d'huile des
grandes villes comme liège namur et
charleroi imite ars talent une manière
pour elle de corriger sur le terrain les
lacunes des règles européennes
alors comment corriger les lacunes
justement de la directive européenne
pour en parler elisabeth morin chartier
bonjour bienvenue vous êtes députée
européenne membre du groupe ppe parti
populaire européen
vous êtes questeur de ce parlement et
vous êtes surtout rapporteur du projet
justement de directives du travail des
tâches et donc pour le parlement
européen donc elle devrait être
présentée en commission d'ici quelques
semaines
oui et non en face de vous guillaume
balas vous êtes également député
européen membre du groupe socialiste
vous avez rédigé un rapport il ya
quelques semaines vous sur le dumping
social vous en parlerez enfin nicolas
govou suivait ce dossier depuis toujours
vous êtes journaliste éditeur du blog
bruxelles 2 et correspondant de sud
ouest bienvenue à vous alors après ce
reportage on voit que la situation est
quelque peu intenable pour les
entrepreneurs on a vu le bâtiment on a
vu le transport vous diriez qu'il s'agit
clairement de dumping social
qu'est-ce qu'on a ratés dans la mise en
place de ce texte elisabeth morin
chartier pour marié à une telle
situation
c'est très clair dans la situation des
travailleurs détachés aujourd'hui en
europe nous reposons sur un texte qui
date de 1996 il y a vingt ans qu'est-ce
que c'était l'europe l'europe c'était 15
états membres avec des écarts de salaire
minimum qui allait de 1 à 3 vingt ans
plus tard l'europe a changé de taille
cette aujourd'hui 28 états membres et
des écarts de salaires qui vont de 1 à
10 ce qui fait que il y a un jeu qui
s'établit à l'intérieur du marché
européen sur ses salaires concurrence
enfin jeu de concurrence un jeu de
concurrence deux salariés et à jules
concurrence d'entreprises un jeu de
concurrence deux salariés parce que il y
à un mouvement évidemment de salariés
qui vont des stones ouest vers les pays
à plus fort salaires et à plus forte
protection sociale s'il ya aussi un
jeune de concurrence entre les
entreprises parce que pour gagner des
appels d'offres
aujourd'hui
on voit des entreprises qui n'hésitent
pas à faire appel à des travailleurs
détachés pour coiffer sur le poteau d
entre eux et on l'a vu effectivement
l'argent comme travailleurs nationaux eu
nicolas gros il n'y a pas eu de
tentative depuis 1996 de revoir ce texte
mais moi je pense que là je suis pas
d'accord avec madame la député à
l'époque de la directive la directive a
été fait pour le maçon portugais ce
qu'on craignait
c'était que les maçons portugais déborde
sur le marché français au moment de
l'adhésion de l'espagne parce que la
directive
elle est née de sa de cette peur il
fallait encadrer et éviter que le
secteur du bâtiment notamment et d'eau
de trois autres secteurs ne soit détruit
par une concurrence déloyale
à l'époque le salaire allait de 1 à 10
entre le portugal et le danemark
donc on avait le même ratio le le
problème c'est que c'est une directive
sellal qui accompagne la lie prestations
de services est pas une directive
sociale c'est une directive qui est
destiné à accompagner en gros une
concurrence loyale entre les entreprises
de part et d'autre elle n'a pas pour but
d'élever le niveau social avait juste
pour but d'éviter une concurrence
déloyale et le deuxième facteur c'est
qu'elle ne concerne que les travailleurs
salariés
c'est cela et aujourd'hui on est face à
un marché qui non seulement à une
différenciation de salaire qui restait
stable parce que les salaires ne sont
pas énormément rapprocher la différence
de l'aspect du portugal et de l'espagne
mais on a un atomisation du marché du
travail où la plupart des travailleurs
ne sont plus salariés de l'entreprise
ils viennent en tant qu'indépendant donc
en gros en tant qu'intérimaire d'une
entreprise même pas intérêts mais à un
sous-traitant de l'entreprise
donc là théoriquement la directive du
travail détachées ne s'acquitte pas en
tant que tel donc ils peuvent au curry
bouyer faire un tarif à 1 euro de
l'heure si vous avez envie c'est votre
problème entre guillemets
d'entrepreneurs individuels
donc là on se trouve face à un nouveau
problème est gérée que c'est un
changement du marché du travail en
europe qui en 20 ans est accomplie donc
il ya tout cet aspect là et la directive
même demain je ne suis pas sûr qu'elle
soit totalement adapté on y reviendra
alors guillaume balas le problème c'est
quoi ce qui pendant ses vingt ans on a
manqué de contrôle on a laissé les abus
s'installer qu'est ce qui s'est passé au
bo je pense que
il ya eu une majorité je dis pas
politique mais une majorité de direction
de l'europe
j'ai considéré que ce qui fait d'abord
confiance était le marché unique et la
libre circulation du capital des
marchandises et des des travailleurs et
que en réalité
l'élargissement notamment de l'europe
alès ne s'est pas accompagnée on le sait
bien d'un approfondissement à l'ouest
d'abord pour qu'on puisse proposer des
règles un petit peu claires et donc on
s'est enfermés dans un système où il y a
une économie low cost entre guillemets à
l'est et une économie menacée maintenant
en tout cas pour ces travailleurs à à
l'ouest donc la question avait très
simple c est ce que l'union européenne
est en capacité de compléter maintenant
le marché intérieur par des règles
sociales qui vont vers un processus
d'uniformisation jeudi un processus
parce que ça va pas du jour au lendemain
évidemment ou est ce qu elle n'y arrive
pas et alors si elles n'y arrivent pas
de manière extrêmement claire moi je
crois qu alors ça sera la fin de l'union
européenne parce que les peuples le
refusons c'est pour ça qu'il ya quatre
ans sur la question du naming absolument
et c'est pour ça qu'on veut avec son
voisin polonais exactement c'est pour ça
que je pense que la question de cette
directive bien sûr ne réglera pas tout
parce que je pense que c'est il faut
attaquer par tous les bouts la question
sociale en europe
évidemment mais elle est quand même
extrêmement importante pourquoi parce
que la question de la clarification
maintenant dans la loi européenne
2 qu'est ce que c'est par exemple la
rémunération d'un travailleur permettra
justement d'amenuiser les jeux entre les
entreprises sur le fait qu'on va payer
moins un tel plutôt que l'autre parce
que l'un des travailleurs détachés et
l'autre est un travailleur locale donc
ce n'est pas un petit débat que nous
avons devant nous et dont elisabeth
morin chartier chargé alors c'est
maintenant japon pour rajouter à un
point parce que je suis totalement
d'accord avec ce que viennent dire
guillaume balas je voudrais rajouter
qu'aujourd'hui même des pays comme la
pologne les pays qui sont situés à l'est
de l'europe commencent eux aussi à avoir
une concurrence déloyale de travailleurs
qui viennent de l'autre côté des
frontières de l'europe qui viennent
d'ukraine et qui viennent à moindre coût
offrir leurs services en travailleurs
détachés dans des pays qui eux sont
honnis
art de travailleurs détachés ailleurs
donc c'est un vaste mouvement européen
sur lequel il faut que nous apportions
de la régulation du contrôle les légions
attendent plus d'europe sociale nos
concitoyens européens
aujourd'hui si on veut qu'ils croient en
l'europe qu'ils se réapproprient c'est
là-dessus qu'il faut un cétacé la lancer
sur laquelle on est attendu qu'il faut à
ce que l'agro vous êtes d'accord
le ver était dans le fruit dès le début
on savait très bien on a fermé les yeux
en se disant ça va passer ya pas de
problème c'est comme d'habitude parce
que en 96 et effectivement au lecteur
dans une autre époque
je me rappelle très bien d'un débat je
peux même cité le nom de la personne
d'une dg de la dg emploi de la
commission européenne lors d'un débat à
l'université de nanterre aridi qui à ce
moment là disait il ya un problème
voici lequel est ce problème c'était pas
le problème du travailleur détachées qui
vient avec une entreprise parce que
l'entreprise un chantier ça pousse ça
pose des problèmes mais disons que ces
modérés et normalement c'est à peu près
encadrés par par la directive
c'est pas le problème non plus de
l'entreprise multinationale qui détache
à travailleurs dans ces différents
groupes ça pose des problèmes mais ça
aussi c'est maîtriser le problème c'est
quand ça se détache par des
triangulaires et ce problème là le
double détachement le double détachement
ça veut dire que c'est une boîte aux
lettres en fait c'est oui si vous
ajoutez mais avec des boîtes d'intérim
vous avez une boîte il n'y a plus aucun
rapport entre le travail le détachement
à l'arrivage des ouvriers par exemple
polonais via une entreprise cypriote
vouziers enregistrés en irlande par
exemple ça c'était le cas typique à
l'époque moi je me rappelle très bien on
avait évoqué sa la moitié des gens
rigolaient certains spécialistes savais
que ça pouvait être le problème mais on
pensait à l'époque
même ceux qui étaient les plus
pessimistes se disait ça va rester
juguler et on verra ensuite parce que si
tu as premiers pas cette directive on va
là et on va là-bas aussi déjà un premier
pas et comme d'habitude on va là on va
là l'a peaufiné au fil du temps on ne
l'a pas peaufiner il ya le dialogue sur
l'inspection du travail c'est de la
foutaise
aucun dialogue nokia aucun contrôle a
pour mouiller aucun contrôle faites ce
que vous voulez effectivement il ya eu
aucun contrôle du coup alors on n'a pas
assez fait on traite le problème c'est
qu'il ya une asymétrie quand même
complète entre les états sur la question
du contrôle ils sont partout insuffisant
mais il y en a où c'est pire qu'ailleurs
et il ya des mesures qui pourraient être
prises parce que là il faut distinguer
deux choses il faut distinguer ce qui
est de l'ordre de l'illégalité qui est
massive et qui pose la question du
contrôle et il faut distinguer ce qui
est de l'ordre des trous dans la
législation aujourd'hui ce à quoi nous
allons nous attaquer là ce sont les
trous dans la législation
il a une directive en 2014 qui a été
posé normalement pour faire en sorte que
ce soit mieux appliquée on peut penser
que healy a aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'insuffisances et notamment une sur le
contrôle
c'est pour ça que il va falloir
maintenant monter d'un cran c'était une
des propositions qui a été ratifié par
le parlement que j'avais faite sur le
fait qu'on mette en place un des équipes
multilatérale au niveau européen avec
plusieurs pays concernés sur la question
du contrôle
c'est la première chose j'ai échoué à
faire passer l'idée d'une inspection
européenne mais je pense que c'est le
bon niveau ouais et la deuxième qui me
paraît absolument aujourd'hui
essentielle c'est d'augmenter le nombre
d'inspecteurs du travail il ya des
normes internationales qui existe
l'organisation internationale du travail
a mis d'énormes nous n'y sommes pas en
europe
aujourd'hui il faut l'écrire et nissan
ont largement parle et enfin un dernier
élément très important parce que vous
avez fait allusion tout à l'heure c'est
sur la question de la sous-traitance
il y a par exemple des pays on peut
prendre la france aujourd'hui ou et les
nouvelles règles aujourd'hui font qu'il
ya une responsabilisation du donneur
d'ordres par rapport à l'ensemble des
sonneurs est inférieure à la moyenne
exactement ça fait râler les grandes
entreprises les idées assez trop
compliqué et c est bien écouter
peut-être qu'il peut y avoir des effets
un petit peu négatif mais on voit
l'effet très largement positif que
pourrait avoir cette mesure je crois
qu'il faudrait y aller mais ça attention
ça n'est pas la question de la
législation européenne en tant que telle
alors justement les discussions vont bon
train depuis des mois pour imaginer le
prochain texte de cette directive est à
des lieues avec lucile devillers et
aurélie la face
être européen
cela veut aussi dire bénéficier de
règles du jeu équitables
cela signifie que les travailleurs car
devrait avoir le même salaire pour le
même travail dans le même pays s'est
faite en septembre dernier jean claude
juncker président de la commission
européenne prévient ses homologues
devant les députés européens
signant la possible fin du dumping
social en europe
il faut dire qu une pression sans
précédent s'exerce sur la commission
européenne et sa commissaire belge
marianne thyssen pour une réforme par le
haut de la directive de 1996 sur le
travail des tâches et abus manque de
contrôle concurrence déloyale les
attaques sont légion jusqu'à la menace
de manuel valls de ne plus appliquer le
texte si celui ci n'était pas réformée
le gouvernement français cherche
aujourd'hui à convaincre et beaucoup de
pays sont d'accord avec lui qu'il faut
changer qu'il doit y avoir une égalité
de traitement par le haut pour lutter
contre le dumping social qu'on doit
payer des cotisations sociales les plus
élevées
le nombre de travailleurs détachés
déclarés en france n'a jamais été aussi
élevé près de 300000 personnes 3300 % de
hausse depuis 2004 le fond d'une réforme
par le haut et soutenue par plusieurs
pays l'allemagne la belgique l'italie
les pays bas et le luxembourg l'espagne
et les pays scandinaves mais
l'opposition est forte dans les pays de
l'est
onze pays dont la pologne principal pays
de départ des travailleurs détachés la
roumanie ou encore la hongrie ont
présenté un carton jaune à la commission
européenne
l'obligeant à revoir sa copie en visite
officielle à varsovie
myriam el khomri ministre du travail a
donc tenté de convaincre son homologue
polonaise sans succès le texte doit pour
être validés être adoptée à la majorité
qualifiée une partie est loin d'être
gagnée alors elisabeth morin-chartier
question volontairement provocatrice
vous croyez vous allez réussir à obtenir
un texte à la hauteur de l'enjeu août et
jeanne et la ferme volonté et le fait
que nous soyons co-rapporteur ma
collègue socialiste
agnès jongerius et moi même donc les
deux grands groupes du parlement
européen travaille ensemble pour
améliorer ce texte est déjà un très bon
signal parce que ça signifie que pour
faire ce texte il faut qu'on change
complètement et qu'on réforme
nos méthodes de travail habituellement
vous savez c'est une affaire que aux
règles politiquement entre les
différents groupes politiques tu es sûr
qu'elle est là on voit une évolution qui
va là on est là sur nos voies la monnaie
plus sur des clivages politiques
on est sur un tricot entre des positions
politiques et des positions nationales
et nous avons besoin de tout le monde au
niveau du parlement européen pour
pouvoir avoir une majorité importante au
parlement de telle sorte deux ans après
et nous puissions peser vis-à-vis du
conseil de conseils dont vous avez vu
qu'au niveau du conseil d'affaires n'est
pas gagné alors justement nicolas grau
pourquoi ce carton jaune
la part de ces onze pays de l'est est ce
qu'ils ne peuvent vraiment pesé est-ce
que ça bloque est ce que ces blocs en
gie ont intérêt c'est vous c'est une
application d'intérêt économique il ya
les limites on sera leur place
effectivement du coup ils disent on sera
plus compétitif c'est un c'est un ratio
de rapports dans les ressources du pays
il faut voir que par exemple pour un
pays comme la pologne selon quand
comment vous prenez les études etc
mais je dirais que l'apport des ouvriers
expatriés quelles que soient les statuts
cesser la troisième ressource à peu près
de la pologne ou la quatrième en fait
tout dépend comment c'est à sa façon
c'est d'abord c'est un apport donc je
dis pas que sans ça ils s'en sortent pas
mais je dirais que donc c'est un vecteur
d'exportation va dire donc ils ne
veulent pas s'en priver
et le carton jaune est ce qu'il est
bloquant pour la commission européenne
est ce que marianne thyssen va devoir
vraiment revoir son texte passé pour moi
la question est plus là et souvent ce
qu'il ya c'est qu'il ya des positions
très fermes avant et qu en général si on
tient fermement le bout et qu'on la
firme finalement parce que si vous
regardez sur le papier la majorité
qualifiée gens vous allez me répondre
n'est pas loin donc ces pays sont
peut-être nombreux mais ils pèsent pas
grand chose d'accord il ne pèse pas
grand chose donc ils n'ont pas la
majorité
j'irai de fait suffisant den d'une part
comme vous avez dit c'est un carton
jaune donc juste il lève le carton puis
c'est tout en gros et on passe si la
commission maintient sa position passe
et si le parlement trouve sa majorité
qualifiée
ils seront en minorité mais la falaise
le texte la sphère est dépassé la sphère
du carton jaune permettez moi de le
préciser
la commission a maintenu sa proposition
le carton jaune était à la commission
elle maintient et nous au parlement nous
avons commencé notre travail et nous
poursuivons notre travail
donc la sphère du carton jaune elle vous
pouvez la prendre comme un indicateur
comme un indice comme un état d'esprit
de ces pays qui ont levé le carton
chaude mais vous ne pouvez plus dire
aujourd'hui que le carton jaune et
bloquant guillaume balas manuel valls
qui dit que si le texte n'est pas à la
hauteur il me l'a appris que la mine ne
l'appliquera plus est ce que c'est
possible je pense quelque chose à éviter
dans cette affaire la première chose
c'est de penser que les pays de l'est ce
sont un bloc
pourquoi parce que on a vu avec
elisabeth morin-chartier aujourd'hui
même des syndicalistes polonais le plus
grand syndicat que tout le monde connaît
en pologne qui s'appelle solidarnost et
qui est pour la révision de la directive
c'est le cas en république tchèque c'est
plat en slovaquie ah oui vous savez ça
voilà les travailleurs les salariés
aujourd'hui demandent la révision de la
directive qui sont nomades dans des
boulots qui sont des bouleaux d
esclavage moderne
donc si vous voulez attention il ya les
gouvernements il ya la société dans ces
pays et cette société elle aspire aussi
au bien-être la deuxième chose à éviter
c'est qu'il ne faut pas non plus
mépriser les pays de l'est dans le sens
que je pense qu'on les a aussi enfermé
dans cette économie low cost là ça
demande des révisions qui sont pas
simplement de l'ordre social mais aussi
que c'est quoi la politique économique
de l'union européenne et de justice sur
les territoires il y aurait à mon avis
beaucoup de choses à dire et je pense
qu'il ya une grande renégociation à
faire avec le pays de l'est aujourd'hui
sur ce sujet et la troisième chose que
vous me posez la question sur notamment
ce qu'a dit manuel valls c'est que je
crois qu'il faut faire extrêmement
attention à ce qu'on raconte sur ces
sujets là il est possible que si tout
échoue et je pense pas que ça sera le
cas mais que si tout échoue un jour
notre pays doivent prendre ses
responsabilités mais attention parce que
si jamais nous en étions là ça serait la
fin de l'aventuré européenne
avec toutes ses conséquences possibles
donc notre urgence aujourd'hui elle
n'est pas de menacer avait de convaincre
et notamment de convaincre les autres
pays que nous pouvons bouger dans cette
affaire il est parfois pas inutile de
mettre une petite épée de damoclès sur
les têtes mais si on en met trop on
braque et on avance plus la menace alec
bidon elle est parce que voilà parce
qu'il veut pas le dire mais moi je vais
vous le dire elle est totalement bidon
valls ont fait un numéro je suis fort et
vous allez voir ce que je vais faire
mais il va s'écraser d'abaisser son slip
parce que non parce que la vraie raison
c'est que les français
combien de français sans travailleurs
détachés bénéficient de cette directive
la troisième pays exportateur et
troisième pays à bénéficier de cette
vérité dont dans ce que l'on perd d'un
côté le problème c'est que ceux qui
perdent sais pas ce qu'ils gagnent mais
globalement la france et plus de l'éveil
à la danse dans cette directive
elle exporte ses travailleurs qui
viennent entre guillemets faire du
dumping dans d'autres pays peut-être
mais vous savez bien qu'ils avaient un
petit jury malin
à ce moment là quand manuel valls a dit
ça parce que je vous rappelle une chose
c'est que si cette directive est
réouverte c'est parce que françois
hollande en tant que président de la
république à 8 même insisté auprès de
ses collègues au conseil pour réouvrir
cette directive dont il y avait un petit
jeu franco français entre le président
de la république et son premier vice
alors elisabeth et vous avez au niveau
européen on peut pas jouer à ça c'est
pas les petits jeux nationaux qui nous
feront avancer
alors justement qu'est ce que vous
proposez dans ce rapport qu est ce qui
pour vous est important ce qui sera
encore importante d'obtenir en fait sur
cette future directive
qu'est ce qui est important d'obtenir
d'abord que l'on ce que l'on soit bien
d'accord
tous ensemble sur la durée du
détachement donc 24 au lieu de 36 24
mois le ca c non non mais là ce que
c'est la proposition 24 mois c'est la
proposition de la commission et donc de
la commissaire marianne thyssen et il
faut voir s'il n'y a pas d'autre
possibilité
on est sur quoi sont deux mois le
détachement non mais vous ne ferez pas
on est en pleine négociation alors vous
savez c'est pas ici que je vais mettre
les menottes pour ne pas pouvoir
négocier
donc on va avoir sur la durée un train
d'arriver et bella sur salaire égal
enfin travailler garder mathieu c'est
justement c'est très important a eu un
texte de la commission aujourd'hui et
pas très clair l'idée c'était de dire en
gros il faut que la rémunération est pas
simplement le salaire des travailleurs
détachés soit égale à la rémunération
des travailleurs locaux ayant clamé
vidéo la deuxième note et une treizième
mois et c'est tout à faire des
conventions collectives ce qu'en france
les conventions collectives sont
généralement d'application universelle
mais il ya des pays céder les
conventions collectives sont les
publications sectorielles bon donc tout
ça est compliqué mais il faut que ce
soit plus clair parce que le texte de la
commission aujourd'hui il énonce des
principes et on voit pas bien où il veut
aller
et il faut bien distinguer ce qui est de
l'ordre du salaire et de ce qu'elle lors
de la rémunération et de qu'est ce qu'on
met entre les deux tout ça doit être
vraiment quelque chose d'indiquer
deuxième élément qui je crois est
extrêmement important c'est lutter
contre les sociétés boîtes aux lettres
c'est pas dans le texte aujourd'hui on
verra si on peut l'améliorer ou pas mais
ce serait
ses soeurs ses maîtres des conditions
sûres qui peut détacher des travailleurs
est ce que une richesse que une
entreprise qui n'a pas 25 % par exemple
de son activité dans un pays peut
vraiment détaché des travailleurs
nicolas grau vous aurez le dernier mot
est ce que comme comme on vient de le
voir il ya une possibilité de sortir un
petit peu par le haut et de faire en
sorte comme le disait le monsieur là le
routier dans le premier reportage de
créer une europe sociale et d'augmenter
les salaires des pays de l'est
je suis pas sûr que la directive des
travailleurs même amélioré permettra
d'augmenter les salaires des pelles scc
la situation économique dans les piles
c'est d'ailleurs si vous regardez la
pologne le salaire minimum a énormément
augmenté dans ces pays c'est pour ça que
petit à petit ils ont un vrai problème
d'ailleurs de de travailleurs qualifiés
en pologne
c'est pas la question d'aujourd'hui moi
je pense que il ya un point qui est
fondamental sur lequel on les européens
devraient réfléchir c'est que pour moi
ce système de façon plus générale de
directives ou dix ans après on se dit
parce qu'après il faudra que les han
il faut encore trois ans pour qu'elle
soit appliquée plus trois ans pour dire
quel est le problème à plus trois ans et
ce sera déjà obsolète elle sera déjà
obsolète il faut qu'on invente un
système comme il ya dans certains pays
en france par exemple comme la
circulaire d'application on puisse très
vite corriger ou interpréter notion qui
dans la directive paraît flou parce
qu'on l'a laissé sciemment flou et ou
parce que de nouveaux phénomènes sont à
sont apparus sans attendre dix ans de
plus pour la mettre en oeuvre et je
pense que c'est à ce niveau là d'une
espèce de délégations qu'on pourrait
faire automatiquement un nouveau corps
n'ait tout simplement à la commission
européenne pour par voie
d'interprétation en attendant la
prochaine directive dire il faut
entendre par travail est rattachée ou
par société intérimaire tel et de
manière à sortir un petit peu duflot
avoir une organisation encore je vais
vous dire une chose y un point qui est
bien c'est qu'on a des directives
d'application qui nous permettent
justement de faire ces évolutions
par contre vous dire une chose c'est que
le parlement est en codécision avec le
conseil et je pense que sur ce point là
je le pouvoir politique doit continuer à
faire évoluer les textes européens
eh bien écoutez merci à tous de nous
avoir expliqué ce dossier un petit peu
difficile parce que c'est vrai que de
prime abord c'est un petit peu abscons
le travail des tâches
donc merci a vous rendez vous la semaine
prochaine ici même avec ahmed tazir
bonne semaine à tous ciao